hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast epigenomic profiles of asthma
i'm rachel brown of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
we have a few important announcements
before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event
you can submit questions by typing them
in the q a box which can be found by
clicking on the green q a button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems
feeling or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem through
the green q a button lower left
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker
dr ivana yang received a phd in
chemistry from unc chapel hill followed
by postdoctoral training with john
quackenbush in functional genomics
she is currently an associate professor
at the university of colorado school of
medicine
colorado school of public health and
national jewish health
the focus of her research over the past
12 years has been on genomic profiles
and pulmonary fibrosis asthma and and
innate immunity
in this work she has identified
molecular subtypes of pulmonary fibrosis
gene expression profiles of
environmental exposures in asthma and
dna
methyl methylation changes associated
with the development of asthma and
pulmonary fibrosis
she currently
expanded her research program to
encompass epigenetic regulation of gene
expression and other diseases and
exposures
including metabolic
disorders
including metabolic disorders
her talk today will focus on asthma
epigenetics i'll now turn it over to dr
yang for her presentation
hello thank you rachel very much for
that kind introduction so what i would
like to do is uh spend the next 45
minutes or so telling you about some of
the work that we've done in epigenomic
profiles of asthma
i will start by introducing uh the
disease and why we care to do this
research
asthma is a major public health problem
it affects a large number of children
and adults worldwide
it is more prevalent among children and
minorities
and so that creates a major public
health issue
for example from 2001 through 2009
asthma rates rose the most among black
children almost a 50 percent increase
the cost of asthma continues to increase
um every year and what is really
interesting if you look at the graph
that i have on the slide is um
and i'm hoping that you can see the
colors of the lines is that
the most uh the most uh the highest rise
in asthma has been in westernized
countries
suggesting that it has to be the
environment and not genetics because our
genetics does not change that quickly
um
especially in westernized countries
that's leading to this increase in
prevalence
um one of the major issues in terms of
trying to understand uh genetic and
environmental basis of asthma
is that it's a very heterogeneous
disease so this is a figure from one of
the review papers that sally wenzel a
leader in the field of asthma
uh clinical research has uh published
and you can see here you don't have to
look at every single um
subtype of asthma but there are many
subtypes
some are specific to childhood some are
specific to adults and then there's some
overlap
and there is a range of severity of
disease as well
um asthma is a complex immunological
disease um
most of the time asthma is characterized
by
th2
cell t cell response however this figure
illustrates that it's not only th2 cells
but other cell types
that can lead to different subtypes of
asthma so some of the heterogeneity of
asthma
is
founded in some of the immune
heterogeneity as well
one important
piece of information to tell you before
i start telling you about the work that
we've done in asthma epigenetics is that
the environment and genetics do not um
generally um act directly on those
immune cells the t cells that i just
mentioned rather this is mediated
through the airway epithelium so what
happens is when an individual is exposed
to allergens or other environmental
exposures is that there is damage to the
airway epithelium and this leads um
downstream to some of the immuno
immunological changes
so when i start telling you about our
work i will focus on two um
two
several projects but all of them are
will be in either immune cells or
epithelial cells
um importantly asthma is an
environmental disease so this um slide
tells you a little bit about some of the
exposures that have been associated with
asthma
the most prevalent exposures are
allergens house dust mite pollens
ragweed cockroach mold
um however there are non-allergen forms
uh non-allergen-induced forms of asthma
air pollution is especially
relevant to these non-allergen-induced
forms of asthma
exercise aspirin infections
when we talk about environment and
asthma we talk about both in utero
exposures so um for example a neutral
exposure to cigarette smoke
increases child's risk of developing
asthma
at the same time if maternal diet is
rich in um
oily fish and fruits and vegetables um
kids are pretty kids have less
risk for asthma
so in addition to direct exposures that
i just mentioned in terms of allergens
and other
factors in utero exposures are also
important
in addition to being an environmental
disease asthma is a genetic disease
estimates of heritability in this
disease are 36 to 79
and a number of geos genome-wide
association studies have been done
recently to identify genetic variants
that are associated with the risk of
asthma
some of these studies have been very
large they're meta-analyses of multiple
studies
so we're talking
tens of thousands of patients and very
sophisticated um genetic chips that have
over a million variants either
covered on the chips
but despite all of this genetic variants
that have identified through jivas
explain a small portion of disease
heritability
so where is this misinheritability
the field of asthma is currently
focusing on two areas
uncovered rare variants so rare variants
may be important um in terms of genetic
risk of asthma
and the other part it may be epigenetic
marks so our lab um has been looking at
epigenetic marks in asthma
so what are epigenetic marks
epigenetic marks
are um
both consist of dna methylation and
histone modifications so they're not in
the dna sequence itself but there are
modifications to either dna or histone
proteins that dna is wrapped around
and so what they do is they um ensure
that genes are expressed in the right at
the right time at the right place and in
the right amount
um
what the different methylation and
histone modification marks will lead to
either areas of open chromatin such as
this area here let me see if i can use
an arrow
to point it
um so this area here is open chromatin
this is where transcription occurs so
dna is accessible um
rna polymerase can come in and you get
gene expression
these areas that are closed chromatin um
there's lack of gene expression because
rna polymerase cannot come in and
initiate that transcription
so epigenetic marks control whether the
chromatin is open or closed
um
epigenetic marks are really important in
a number of very basic cellular
processes
so and um
at the level of the organism not just
cellular
so for example they are responsible for
x chromosome inactivation in females
as you know
females have two copies of the x
chromosome but we do not have twice as
much expression of the genes that are
encoded on the x chromosome and the
reason is epigenetics so if genetic
marks silence transcription from one of
the copies of the x chromosome
epigenetic marks are also very important
in regulation of tissue-specific gene
expression so genes that are expressed
in the lung are not expressed in the
colon for example and that's regulated
by
epigenetics
as i mentioned already about asthma the
same is true for epigenetic marks
environmental exposures both in utero
and direct lead to changes in epigenetic
marks
and finally
epigenetic marks this regulation of
these epigenetic marks has been
associated with disease
um a number of studies for a long time
have been done in the field of cancer
and looking at the genetics in cancer
but more recently non-malignant diseases
such as asthma and other
lung diseases and
diabetes and so on
researchers in this field have started
looking at epigenetics
in addition to
being regulated by the environment
epigenetic marks are also important in
differentiation of t cells so if you
remember a number of slides ago i told
you that uh
asthma is characterized allergic asthma
is mostly characterized by th2 response
exaggerated th2 response but there are
other forms of asthma with other th
cell subtypes what's really important to
know is that these um
the um
differentiation of a naive cd4 positive
t cells to different lineages so how the
cell
is going to become whether the cell will
become th1 th2 th17 this is regulated by
epigenetics so transcription factors
that regulate these um
transcription factors and cytokines as a
matter of fact that regulate this um
differentiation are also epigenetically
regulated
so an example of that is uh shown in
this slide um there are two um genes
that are shown here
um t-bed one a transcription factor
that's important in th1 cell lineage and
gada3 which is a transcription factor
important in th2 cell lineage on the top
the th
zero so unpolarized undifferentiated
cell has both green and red um histone
modifications so um
red green crystal modifications on this
slide depict those that
are permissive and lead to open
chromatin and gene transcription
versus red
similar to a stop sign
means that
they repress transcription
so what you can see on the left
is in th1 cells
um the tb
tibet one primo um gene only has
green um histone modifications so it is
expressed in th1 cells
on the other hand in th2 cells it is
gata3 that is expressed because
it has only green histone modifications
so this simple illustration just tells
you how this works in terms of uh cell
differentiation
so to put together all the background
that i told you about and our thoughts
on why epigenome is important in asthma
we think that epigenome is a critical
mediator of both exposures and genetic
susceptibility factors on
transcriptional profiles and then this
leads to differences or this is
associated with differences in th
cell skewing which again is also
regulated epigenetically
and this leads to uh development of
different forms of asthma
on this slide i only depict allergic and
non-allergic asthma but if you remember
there are a number of different subtypes
so
there are generally two types of
epigenetic marks that we um think of
traditionally
dna methylation and histone
modifications however non-coding rnas
are often put together um and um
considered part of the epigenome
just to remind you how these marks work
so dna methylation when
promoters of genes are unmethylated that
leads to transcription when they are
methylated that leads to lack of
transcription this is a really basic
uh paradigm however more recent studies
have shown that this is not always the
case so there is gene body methylation
so it's not only promoters and then
sometimes you can have methylation and
expression going in the same direction
not necessarily anti-correlated
histone modifications are much more
complex and i'm not going to talk a lot
about them today i'm mostly focusing on
methylation
but um just to say that there are a
number of different modifications to
histone tails
some of them lead to open chromatin so
they're permissive
or poised sometimes so the promoters are
poised for transcription
and these are depicted in my slides as
green
just like um on the previous on a couple
of slides ago on
the th cells
on the other hand there are also a
number of marks um that on histone tails
that lead to a
repression of gene expression so closed
chromatin and these are depicted in red
and i'm not going to talk a whole lot
about micrornas
in any case
together these
epigenetic marks lead either to gene
transcription on the left or lack of
gene transcription on the right
so to start to test um our hypothesis
that epigenetic marks are important in
asthma our group did a animal study a
number of years ago
um so we tried to um test this
hypothesis that the epigenome is a key
um
mediator of the environmental exposure
in the context of a genetically
vulnerable host and that this leads to
environmental asthma
so um
this slide summarizes some of the
evidence that i already discussed why we
have this hypothesis so um epigenetics
and asthma both have in common that they
have non-mendelian pattern of
inheritance they have parent of origin
effects they're influenced by the
environment affected by neutral
exposures and alter or involve
maturation of t cells
so our specific hypothesis for this
study was that methylation marks cue
towards the th2 phenotype by altering
the transcriptional activity of critical
genes that enhance the risk of allergic
airway disease
we tested this hypothesis in
a mouse model where pregnant females
were fed high versus low methyl um donor
diet
um and what we saw
were differences in asthma phenotypes so
um
in the progeny so in the f1 progeny so
uh
mice born to these mothers on different
diets um
had um if they were if their mothers
were on high metal diet they had more
airway resistance so this is um in
response to inhaled metacholine so this
really um is relevant to asthma in terms
of um
the
airway constriction
compared to low methyl donor um
diet mothers that had a lot less
airway resistance
um
the
the the same was true for um allergic
inflammation so mice um whose mother
preferred high methyl donor diet had
more eosinophils
and il13 in the lavage fluid from their
lungs
and i should have mentioned all of this
was done in a
animal model of allergic airway disease
um house dust mite model
so all these animals were sensitized and
challenged to house dust mites the
differences between groups were really
just the diet of the mother
these phenotypes were transmitted to the
f2 generation
and we did a genomic profile of
methylation dna methylation and
identified 82 hypomethyl hypermethylated
i apologize loci so more methylation um
as a result of high methyl donor diet
including rex 3 and ranks 3 is a
transcription factor that's important in
th cell lineage
so this really ties back to some of the
introduction that i um talked about in
terms of th cells
um and um
th cell lineage um and um epigenetic
regulation and how this is linked to
asthma
um
we also showed that expression of rhondx
iii in splenocytes from these mice was
restored by five as a treatment five aza
is a demethylating agent so when dna
gets demethylated
so back to its
normal state
um
the animals do not have
as much asthma
well this study um that was done in
animals and animals was really important
um
some of the follow-up studies looking at
methyl donors specifically folate so the
biggest um
uh methyl donor in terms of the most
important methyl donor in terms of
supplementation is folate or folic acid
um and since we published this study in
mice there have been a number of human
studies that have looked at association
of maternal folate during pregnancy
and
childhood asthma
and the results have been mixed so there
are um six references on this slide
three were positive three were negative
so really mixed results
um but one of the studies that measured
that did not look at just questionnaire
data for folate rather they measured
serum folate in the uh in the mothers
showed a positive association
so the jury i think is still out on
whether folate maternal folate is
important in
the risk of asthma in children
but again this study that we did in mice
was important in the context of starting
a research area of looking at epigenetic
marks and childhood asthma
so that is what i'm going to spend the
rest of the talk talking about i will
talk about four studies uh that we have
done
um looking at um association of dna
methylation and childhood asthma in
human cohorts i will start by two
studies relevant to
immune cells peripheral blood
methylation and serum ige levels
uh pbmc methylation and allergic asthma
in the inner city and then i'll finish
up by a couple of studies of looking at
nasal epithelial cells so remember the
epithelium is also respiratory
epithelium is also important in asthma
um and i'll talk about
nasal epithelial cell methylation and
allergic asthma in the inner city as
well as some very preliminary data
on
dna methylation and monozygotics twins
discordant for asthma
so the first study that i will talk
about was uh led by bill cookson and
maria moffat in the uk so we were
collaborators on this study and we
worked on this for a while with them um
they have a unique cohort of
kids with asthma where they have
discordant and concordant sibling pairs
as well as some trios
and using this study design
and profiling
dna methylation on illumina arrays for
450k aluminum methylation arrays we
identified 36 loci
that are significantly hypomethylated in
peripheral blood of asthmatic sibs
compared to non-asthmatic sibs so in
these manhattan plots that i will show
you show you on the y-axis is negative
log of the p-value on the x-axis is the
chromosome and then the line of
significance
uh so in this case false discovery rate
of uh less than .01 is drawn and in some
cases i don't have the line of
significance but i'll discuss how we uh
establish significance
so again in this study we identified 36
hypomethylated loci
um
bill and miriam really approached this
study um as
a genetic study so what they did is um
in addition to looking at the original
population so mrca is the original
population they replicated these results
in two additional cohort and performed
the meta-analysis
and what you can see is that um some of
the low side that are listed here are
highly significant in all three cohorts
as well as in the meta-analysis
and all of them are related to um
immune systems so il-4 is very important
in allergic asthma io5 receptor
as well and so on
some of the network analyses that they
perform that i'm not going to talk about
in detail
um showed that eosinophils are the key
cell type um in the
this analysis of peripheral blood and
relationship to ige which makes sense
because the asynophils are the cell type
that is associated with allergic asthma
so in addition to looking at whole blood
methylation as done
on this slide um we also looked at um
specifically in
eosinophils because epigenetic marks are
cell type specific
and we were able to show that many of
these loci that we identified in whole
blood are also differentially methylated
in eosinophils so you can see that i'm
showing you results for six loci and all
of them are hypermethylated in allergic
cosmetics compared to controls and
asthmatics that are not allergic so that
who have low ige are somewhere in the
middle
so this paper really established it was
the first epigenome-wide association
study or eros
in relation to serum ige
and asthma and really
established that epigenetic marks are
important
in
peripheral blood of
children with asthma
in another cohort
this is now a slightly different cohort
these are african-american children and
if you remember from my first slide i
told you that asthma is more prevalent
among african-american children so this
is why we focused on um
this population
we had peripheral blood money nuclear
cells or pbmcs from african-american
children who live in inner cities
and we profiled 97 allergic cosmetic
cases and 97 controls
this analysis identified 81 regions
differentially methylated regions that
are significantly associated with asthma
so the reason i don't have a
significant threshold on this slide is
because these are regions and the way we
calculated p-values is by combining
p-values of multiple probes within a
region so i'm demonstrating here with
the arrows
and that is what was significant not
individual probes
network analysis of these 81
differentially methylated regions showed
hypomethylation so in the same direction
as our eosinophil study less methylation
um in key genes that are important in
regulation of gene expression and asthma
il13 for example is a very important
cytokine um runks3 remember the
transcription factor that i mentioned in
our
mouse study is also hypomethylated in
asthmatic children
um in addition to looking at dna
methylation we also wanted to look at
gene expression and how
these methylation marks affect uh gene
expression um so in this very simple
plot i'm plotting expression uh full
change on the y-axis and it's on the
log2 scale
and on the x-axis is methylation change
percent methylation change
um and what you can see is that um i
don't have a p value for this enrichment
but there are more blue dots so blue
dots
are um
for loci where a methylation and gene
expression have inverse correlation this
is the canonical relationship of dna
methylation and expression
versus red are going in the same
direction
another way we analyzed uh methylation
and gene expression data was by by
combining expression and methylation t
statistics
in the um so doing statistical model
with both in the same model and this
analysis um identified the some of the
same candidates that were identified by
dna methylation analysis alone so ranks
3
io13 for example but it also identified
additional genes where we did not have
enough power when we looked at just
methylation data but by combining with
expression data we see that for example
il4
so cytokine that was differentially
methylated in relation to ige as well as
st2 which is a um
the receptor for il33 another important
cytokine in asthma they're both
hypomethylated and overexpressed
um so one of the key things that um we
always have to do in terms of validation
of these genomic uh
profiles is um
technical validation and also external
validation so what i mean by that is
replication
does this replicate in a different
population
in this study
all the methylation marks that we
identified were validated technically so
they are differentially ex methylated in
the same kids
and we had partial external validation
so about seven out of ten so 70
of these were validated in an
independent population
um although i'm not going to talk about
histone marks a lot in this presentation
and our lab has not done a lot of work
on histone modifications i just wanted
to mention this paper that came out at
the end of last year
uh where
epigenomic profiles so enhancer profiles
of th1 and th2 cells
were published
by another group because i think it's a
really important resource and also what
they were able to show is that
th1 and th2 cells from asthmatics
compared to healthy controls have very
different enhancer profiles
so this goes together with our data on
dna methylation
demonstrating that epigenetic marks are
altered in asthma
um
so the second part of my talk will focus
on
the respiratory epithelium
as you if you remember from my
introduction um in addition um to
looking at
immune cells it's really important to
look at the epithelium because it gets
injured
and this is how the allergens and other
exposures
get to the immune cells
so
in children it's very difficult to do
bronchoscopies um it's and get airway
epithelial cells and for this reason a
number of researchers have started using
nasal epithelial cells as a surrogate
for um
airway epithelial cells
so in a seminal paper
published by max cybold's group at
national jewish one of my colleagues it
was shown that uh the nasal
transcriptome um is very similar to the
airway transcriptome and that this um
also that there are changes associated
with childhood asthma in the nasal
transcriptome that are similar
to uh what happens in the arab
transcriptome
um
at the same time there was another study
um by andrea carelli's group that
showed uh differences in dna methylation
in nasal cells of children with asthma
compared to controls
and similarly a
paper from pedro avila's group
showing that human rhinovirus infection
causes different meth causes different
dna methylation changes in nasal
epithelia of asthmatics compared to
controls
so all of these uh publications um
demonstrated that the nasal epithelium
is a good surrogate for the airway
epithelium um and we started looking at
um the epithelial nasal epithelial cells
in our cohorts
um so the way we did this is um we
were able to collect uh nasal epithelial
samples on about half of the subjects
that were involved enrolled in our
original population of 97 cases and 97
controls that i
talked about in the pbmc study
of those
um we selected 36 cases and 36 controls
that have most pure columnar epithelia
and this was accessed by fox j1 gene
expression and fox j1 is a transcription
factor that's very specific to uh
ciliated cells
so the reason we do this is that we're
really interested when you do a nasal
brushing sometimes you get a mix of
squamous and uh columnar epithelia and
we're really only interested in columnar
epithelia because the those are the
cells that uh represent that are similar
to the area epithelia so we use this
to identify only samples that are really
representative of the airway epithelia
when we
perform the genome-wide methylation
profiling
we did this in the same way that we did
it
in the pbmc study as well as in the ige
uh study so it's illumina 450k
methylation arrays
and this analysis identified a stronger
signal than what we found in the
pbmcs although our population was
smaller
so we identified 119
differentially methylated regions or
dmrs that's plotted
in the panel a of the figure on the
manhattan and we also identified 118
single cpg sites that are associated
after adjustment for multiple
comparisons
and what i should tell you that i didn't
tell you before in all our analyses
um we run uh linear models and we adjust
for confounders such as age gender and
ethnicity and race because we know that
these um
can influence methylation in addition to
that we do a lot of quality control and
we
deal with batch effects before we get to
statistical models
so what are some of the genes that are
differentially methylated in the nasal
epithelia
um
if you look at the differentially
methylated regions and differentially
methylated probes or positions so these
are again regions of sustained low p
values
associated with
asthma
or
single cpg sites that are significant
after adjustment for multiple
comparisons
um there's some overlap
which is not surprising um
there are about 40 loci that overlap but
there are 70 to 80 that are unique to
the two analyses and i think this really
illustrates that it's important to look
at the data in multiple ways
when you do these genomic profiles
when we take the union of this venn
diagram that i'm showing you we identify
a number of genes that we know are
important in asthma
so um alox 15 is one of the genes that's
been associated with asthma extensively
kelpines um histamine and metal
transferase is important in the allergic
part so allergy periosteum is
differentially expressed in the airway
epithelium of
asthmatics and it's a biomarker that's
that is being used for asthma
we also see changes in methylation of
genes related to extracellular matrix
immunity cell adhesion airway
obstruction
obesity which is also associated with
asthma so there is a subtype of asthma
that's related to obesity
autophagy so again these are all
cellular processes that we know are
important
in asthma
um when we compare these loci to those
that we identified in pvmcs only four of
them overlapped and they're not very
exciting genes that we know are
important in asthma so what this really
tells you is how important it is to look
at different samples um and this is not
surprising given that we're looking at
epithelial cells versus um more immune
cells in the pbmcs
um so it's not surprising that
methylation changes are different given
what we know about cell specificity of
epigenetic marks
these are just some representative plots
of
differentially methylated regions
that we identified as
associated with asthma so on the y-axis
are is the methylation change and then
um
on the x-axis is genomic coordinate so
for example methyltransferase like juan
med1 has only one probe that's um
associated with asthma
versus um
mhc2 dp alpha one for example has a
number of probes so that's what's on the
x-axis uh what this histogram is of um
is of the methylation marks in the
percent methylation estimate in 36 cases
and 36 controls
so um controls are in red cases are in
blue and what you can see is that uh
three of the four representative loci
that i'm showing you're hypomethylated
and asthma so less methylation in the
blue compared to red
versus um the hla dpa1 locus is
hypermethylated so more methylation
i'm hoping that you can see the y-axis
um and um i'll also be able to
illustrate this point on the next slide
but um
what's important here is that these
methylation changes are larger so when
we looked at in pbmcs we found
methylation changes between asthmatics
and controls under order of one to five
percent so very small changes very
consistent but small when we look in
nasal epithelia these are changes from
ranging from 10 to 30 percent and if you
look at uh epigenomic profiles in cancer
these methylation change differences are
approaching those identified in cancer
so
again this is um these are big changes
um because these are big changes it was
very easy to validate both internally so
technical validation and externally by
pyrosequencing
um similar to our pbmc study we also
looked at a relationship of dna
methylation and expression um and this
this is exact same layout of the plots
well i just have two plots because i
have regions and a single
um
probes single cpg sites and you can see
that there is um an enrichment so on
this graph i actually do have the p
values for the enrichment
of um
hypomethylated or
of inverse correlations of
methylation and gene expression
as we would expect
we also analyze the data slightly
differently focusing on what is
differentially expressed so we
use genomic arrays to look at gene
expression and identified for 53 genes
that are significantly differentially
expressed in asthmatics compared to
controls
many of the genes that are
differentially expressed are
those that we know are important in
biology of asthma i mentioned alex 15 is
differentially methylated it's also
differentially expressed
there are a number of other genes that
are related to asthma and allergy as
well as immunity
and some that have been shown to be
consistently differentially expressed
across multiple studies
and some that are used as biomarkers
so looking at these 53 genes and this is
just the plot that i'm showing you is uh
plots the
expression uh for asthmatics on the
y-axis and on the controls on the x-axis
um
the
red dots are genes that are not
differentially expressed and then blue
dots are the ones that are significantly
differentially expressed with the
the size of the dot being proportional
to the full change so difference in gene
expression
so what we wanted to do while we're
interested in expression we're really
mostly interested is in how dna
methylation regulates this expression
response
um so
what we did is we um
looked at um methylation a relationship
of ventilation and expression
quantitatively
just in these 53 genes
and after adjusting for multiple
comparisons we found that 32 out of 53
so 60 of the genes have significant
methylation expression relationships
this is a significant enrichment uh
compared to if we compare
genome-wide how many significant
methylation expression relationships we
have there's an enrichment in these
genes that are differentially expressed
and these are predominantly canonical
inverse relationships 25 out of 32.
um to begin to understand uh the biology
of
these 32 genes uh we performed the
network analysis using protein-protein
interaction data
from the
um
from the innate database of interactomes
and using the network analyst
tool that's available online
in this
network graph
genes that are
upregulated in expression and
hypomethylated so less methylation more
expression
are in red and inversely genes that are
downregulated in expression and
hypermethylated in terms of methylation
are in green
and what you can see in this graph is
that we identified a number of modules
within this network
with genes that we know are important in
asthma
so this um rpk2 gene or ripk2 gene is
really important in innate immune
response in relation to um asthma and
other immune diseases
ccl5 is a chemokine um and so on and
some of the hla genes are in here as
well
um so again this really illustrates how
network analysis can help you find
modules of important uh genes with both
changes in differential expression and
methylation
so what are some of the conclusions that
we can draw from the studies that i've
shown you so far
uh well i think i've shown you that
methylation marks regulate serum ig
concentrations and peripheral blood um
of asthmatic and non-asmat compared to
non-asthmatic children
um i showed you that methylation of
pbmcs
and nasal epithelia are associated with
allergic asthma in inner city children
um
i did
it's important to remember that
methylation marks in pvmcs and nasal
epithelia are different uh which is
again not surprising given how different
these cell types are
um
importantly i showed you that asthma
associated changes in methylation of
nasal epithelia have a much larger
signal in comparison to pbmcs so when uh
looking at um
we know that we can't look at the lung
of children with
asthma but in identifying surrogate
tissue the
tissue or sample that we can use
nasal cells are preferable to pvmcs
um i've shown you in all these studies
that methylation changes are associated
with changes in gene expression
and in my last study of the nasal
epithelia the genes that are expressed
by the nasal epithelium and asthmatic
children appear to be epigenetically
regulated
so while we think epigenetics is really
important it is also important to
remember that epigenetics is just one of
the or the epigenome is just one of the
pieces of the puzzle
and this slide i think demonstrate that
that really well
um that it's important to look at
the epigenome the genome transcriptome
but it's also
microbiome
nutrition and other
pieces that
are important in asthma
so to start to be able to focus on the
environment
and a microbiome uh we
just started a study
um in monozygotic twins and why use
twins well the reason that we are using
twins is that this really allows us and
especially monozygotic twins is this
allows us to remove the effect of
genetics and it allows us to focus more
on the environment
small epigenomic studies in twins in
other diseases and one um that's been
published in asthma has shown increased
power to detect associations
and then using both and monozygotic and
dizygotic twins would also allow us to
estimate heritability of
asthma-associated ventilation marks
um so as i mentioned this is a study
that we're really just beginning and i
have just the one slide a very
preliminary data but i think they're
exciting data and so i wanted to share
them
so
in a small study of all monozygotic twin
pairs
10
discordant for asthma 10 concordant for
asthma so both have asthma and 10
concordant for non-asthma so both twins
are not asthmatic
um we performed a genome-wide
methylation study again using 450
methylation erased from illumina the
same platform that i've talked about
throughout the talk
and in this study we identified 62
differentially methylated regions in
nasal epithelia that are associated with
asthma
what we thought was really interesting
is that there is
um enrichment um so high percentage of
genes um in the 62 loci
are
associated with the nean immunity we did
not see this in the other study and we
think it's because we are able now to
focus in on this innate immune response
to the environment
because we've removed the effect of
genetic genetics
um
in very preliminary analyses half of the
dmrs so differentially methylated
regions are associated with difference
in endotoxin levels into bedding dust
so endotoxin levels in the bedding dust
are um an environmental exposure and the
toxin is part of grain negative bacteria
and so it shows uh
what is um going on in the environment
and we also in collaboration with kathy
lozapone a fantastic
microbiome researcher here at the
university of colorado we looked at uh
the microbiome in the nasal epithelial
cells so in the same sample of these
children and we also were able to show
that half of the dmrs are also
associated with difference in abundance
of some hydrocarbon degrading bacteria
in the nose
so again um this is very preliminary
very early but i think it really
illustrates
how
the right study design in term in this
case using monozygotic twin pairs can
help you identify
important
epigenetic marks um when you're trying
to focus on the environment
so what are the implications of um what
i've told you about today
um so we think methylation marks
especially in the nasal epithelia could
be used as biomarkers of asthma
however
it is really important to realize that
these studies are very early and that we
need to better understand
the relationship of these methylation
marks to disease activity
allergy exposures and treatments
um
they also we think are novel targets for
understanding biology of asthma
especially given their relationship to
gene expression
and their potential therapeutic targets
since methylation can be modified
so let me finish up by just telling you
a little bit about epigenetic therapies
um this is a summary slide from our
recent or relatively recent review
article that shows you all the um
therapeutics that are available for
affecting dna methylation and histone
modifications
um so if you focus on dna
methyltransferase inhibitors there are a
number of them they have been in
clinical trials and
cancers
they have not been
looked at in the context of
non-malignant diseases yet but they are
available
one of the problems with these dna
methyltransferase inhibitors is that
they are non-specific so they will
dimethylate the entire genome or many
loci in the genome not just the locus
that you're interested in demethylating
some of the history modifying
therapies are
more
specific in the sense that they target
the pathway
however none of them are specific to the
point that we would want to say we would
like to target for example just th two
genes and asthma
however there's a lot going on in terms
of using uh genome editing technologies
to develop locus-specific epigenetic
therapies and i'm just listing three
studies um that you can look more into
in terms of how other labs are starting
to
use genome editing
techniques such as crispr cas9
technology to um so what they do is they
fuse the
crispr domain to a histone or dna
modifying enzyme domain and are able to
affect methylation or histone
modification just at a specific locus
and it's really important to know that
this is very early on in terms of
development of these locus-specific
therapies but
i think that they will be available in
the future and um we should um
by then we should know a lot more
answers about how important epigenetic
marks are in asthma um and hopefully
have all the results that would
enable us to use some of these therapies
in the future
so with that i would like to finish my
presentation i would like to acknowledge
individuals who have contributed to this
work and there are a lot of them
um first of all in our laboratory bet
davidson and karen hennessy did all the
lab work brent patterson is a very
talented bioinformatician who did all
the analyses
um
in terms of the inner city asthma
consortium studies so these are children
from the inner city with asthma um
there are a number of collaborators
these samples were collected across the
country um and these are just the
collaborators who have participated um
the mrca cohort so the study that i
mentioned um in terms of a relationship
of ige crm ige and dna methylation
was done uh by bill cooks and miriam
alpha and les mingliand uh we were
collaborators in this study
and then finally um the early studied uh
the early results that i showed you from
our twin cap study so this is study of
twins in colorado and in relation to
asthma i would like to acknowledge those
investigators as well
thank you for your attention and i will
be happy to answer questions
thank you for the informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session i would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the q a box
which can be found by clicking on the
green q a button at the lower left of
the presentation window
our first question reads
not being in the area of genetics my
question is why do we get dysregulation
and methylation in the first place are
there publications addressing this
question in any disease condition
that's a really good question um there
are a lot of publications um
the as i mentioned early on really the
longest the disease that this has been
studied the longest in is cancer
but other diseases um so if you just go
to pubmed and put
dna methylation and diabetes dna
methylation and
obesity dna methylation and i don't know
pick a disease rheumatoid arthritis you
will see that there are now publications
showing association of dna methylation
and
changes in dna methylation and
disease development
why do they happen they're dysregulated
probably for a variety of reasons
some of them are in utero exposures so
um
i use the example of cigarette smoke but
in another study that i'm doing we're
finding this regulation of dna
methylation
in kids whose mothers had gestational
diabetes during pregnancy
they can be
dysregulated by
environmental exposure so if you live in
a polluted city
there may be dysregulation
they are really focusing on the
environmental piece
but also there are publications that
demonstrate that genetic factors can
also regulate dna methylation
so if you have a genetic variant
in a specific place in a genome
methylation marks around that genetic
variant might be altered by the present
of that
variant
great so it looks like that was the only
submitted question so we'll go ahead and
wrap it up today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
november 2015. you will receive an email
from labyrinths alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay
we we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye
you